- Welcome to Pakistan Chowk.
This is a busy, busy kinda
energetful, ultimately,
energetic market in Karachi, Pakistan,
and we are here to eat what
is one of the ultimate,
one of the most beloved Karachi,
Pakistani street food snacks.
It's called a bun kebab.
(rhythmic music)
(traffic sounds)
(speaking in foreign language)
Very good, thank you.
Welcome to the iconic Karachi bun kabab.
- Yeah, finally.
- This is our last bite
together on this Pakistan
food trip of a lifetime.
- This is so iconic that it
should have been the last one.
- Yeah, this is something we
could not miss in Karachi.
- Because they say all
that's well that ends well.
(laughing)
So, it can't end better than this.
(group chattering)
(traffic sounds)
(rhythmic music)
- Okay, so the Karachi bun kebab,
it is a street food snack of wonders,
and it is just amazing to
watch them as they make it.
It takes you some time to even figure out.
He does it so unbelievably fast,
it takes you some time to even
process what even happens.
There's a pan of, I
believe that they're little
vegetable patties, mini sliders,
and then he has this pan
of what looks like foam,
but they said it's whipped-up egg white,
so he grabs one of the patties,
sticks it with his hand into
the pan of egg white foam,
and then drops it into the
oil into a little patty,
and so, the little vegetable
patty is within the foam egg,
and then it fries in oil,
and he does that until
the entire pan is full.
Once the entire pan is full, he remembers
where he added the first one,
and then starts flipping them,
and when he flips them, you
can see that the little patty
is beneath that egg foam.
(speaking in foreign language)
And it almost looks like
a completely new form,
like a molecular gastronomy fried egg,
but instead of a yolk, you
have that little patty in it.
(rhythmic music)
The second part of the bun
kebab is the bun itself,
and it just is a straight-up bun,
but they add some oil to the hot griddle.
They just let it sizzle in the oil until
it just toasts perfectly.
(group chattering)
(rhythmic music)
He lets it toast until
it's perfectly golden,
then he adds on some
chutney onto that bun,
and then he adds on some onions,
and then he adds on the little patty,
and then just wraps it up like a burger.
That is a Karachi bun
kebab, one of the ultimate
Karachi, Pakistani street food snacks.
It's so beautiful to watch
them as they make it.
They do it in such precision.
They could do it with their eyes closed,
and we got some fresh bun kebabs
to try, Karachi bun kebabs.
It looks like a completely
new form of a fried egg,
yeah, deconstructed and
with a little patty inside
instead of the yolk.
It's just a perfect,
little handheld creation,
and let's just try it first
before we dunk it into the chutney.
- [Men] Cheers.
(laughing)
- And, by the way, it's vegetarian,
but you would not even know.
- Really?
- It's very good.
That tastes like a lentil
patty, and then that's like
the foamiest, fluffiest, deep fried egg.
- And that questionable chutney.
(laughing)
- Okay, we gotta dip it into this chutney,
and some of those onions as well.
(rhythmic music)
I'm just gotta dunk the
entire thing in there,
in that chutney.
In one swipe, I got like half
the chutney on the plate.
That is a beautiful thing.
We found out from the
owner that the little patty
is a mixture of minced beef
and some kind of a lentil, right?
Actually, the lentils
really come in nicely,
but it's actually not that
much meat, but you do taste
a little bit of the ground
beef, but mostly lentils.
They add that creamy lentil taste.
- [Ali] Chutney, boys.
(laughing)
- [Mark] Chutney, boys.
(rhythmic music)
(laughing)
- Done.
Done.
- Wow.
- He slammed it.
(laughing)
Ali pulled a two biter, the slider.
Oh man, that is just extraordinary.
This is one of the
ultimate, fast food burgers
I've ever had in my life.
The combination of those creamy lentils
with that ground beef, and
then with that chutney,
it just bumps it up.
You taste the coriander in that chutney.
You taste the slight hardness of it.
The onions in there, and then the bun
is so buttery and crunchy.
It just works.
It's dangerously tasty.
You could just stand
here and eat bun kebab,
after bun kebab, after bun
kebab, listening to the traffic,
watching them as they cook.
This is an establishment.
Every bite needs to be
wiped up with that chutney,
and grab some onions as well.
The coriander seed on that bite.
Oh, wow, it is unbelievably good.
Okay, now I know why this place
is so popular and so legendary.
It is that good.
- You wanna know one more
thing, these are 30 rupees each.
That's 25 cents.
That's eight Baht.
- That's four for a dollar.
I got a massive wipe
of chutney on my lens.
(rhythmic music)
Oh, wow, that is everything you want
in a patty stuffed within a bun.
That is Karachi in a bun.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Thank you.
- [Mark] That's amazing.
It's so good.
- You like it?
- Amazing, yes.
And the owner here is
so nice, so friendly.
Go and check them out.
Super biryani and bun
kebab in Pakistan Chak,
Karachi, Pakistan.
What a spot, and what energy here.
I loved it.
That was one of the greatest
street food, handheld snacks
I think I can think of that I've ever had.